Trascrizione: Gianluca Finocchiaro
Revisore: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Non è facile salire su questo palco
subito dopo lo speaker che abbiamo visto.
Va bene, ci provo.
Mi chiamo Leandro Agrò
e effettivamente sono il primo designer che,
oggi, è qui sul palco
e quindi non vedrete grandi tecnologie
o conquiste dello spazio,
ma magari qualcosa che ha a che fare
col mondo delle idee
e soprattutto con i comportamenti.
La storia che vi racconto oggi
ha a che fare con la Internet degli oggetti.
È la definizione che usiamo
per il prossimo passo di evoluzione della rete Internet,
e ha a che fare con il contributo che il design
può dare alla Internet degli oggetti.
È una storia sostanzialmente divisa in tre atti:
tecnologia, salute e design.
Tecnologia.
Beh, oggi vediamo cose incredibili,
ma io voglio partire veramente da lontano,
perché, qui ci sono due foto:
in una delle due immagini,
beh, sono io,
scegliete voi quale potrebbe essere quella giusta,
e la foto è stata scattata
oltre 40 anni fa in Sicilia.
E se io penso un po' all'universo immaginario della mia fanciullezza
la cosa che mi colpisce
è quanto fosse più disponibile l'accesso alla fantascienza
che non l'accesso alla scienza
che invece era difficile, lontana insomma.
E forse per questo,
le prime letture davvero appassionanti --
ma ero un po' più grande, insomma, della foto --
hanno avuto a che fare con la robotica.
La robotica l'ho incontrata,
come probabilmente molti di noi, attraverso Isaac Asimov.
Il mondo raccontato da Asimov
aveva una elegantissima coerenza,
basata sostanzialmente su tre semplici leggi:
le leggi della robotica sono delle leggi di buon senso, sostanzialmente.
La prima per esempio dice che un robot non può fare male,
non può creare del danno,
neanche con la propria inazione,
ad un essere umano
La seconda dice che un robot
deve obbedire agli esseri umani
però, a meno che questa obbedienza
non contraddica la prima legge.
E la terza legge
sostanzialmente dice che un robot
deve avere cura di sé,
deve proteggere la propria esistenza,
a meno che questo non contraddica
la seconda e la prima legge.
Al di là dell'eleganza da scrittore
con cui questa legge è formulata,
e al di là della enorme coerenza
che dà all'Universo raccontato da Asimov,
la cosa che oggi, da designer, mi colpisce.
è che queste leggi non parlano di specifiche tecniche.
Non dicono quanto deve essere alto un robot
o quanta forza deve avere per non essere aggressivo,
per essere accettabile.
Parlano dei suoi comportamenti.
E questo, dal mio punto di vista,
è l'anima più profonda del designer.
L'altra domanda, oggi, da designer, è quella:
eh sì ma, com'è successo tutto ciò?
Come fa l'umanità a rendersi conto
quando ha bisogno di leggi del genere,
e regolamenta un intero universo?
Beh, di solito le leggi di questo tipo
avvengono dopo dei disastri, ecco:
sono reattive, in qualche modo, a ciò che va storto.
E invece abbiamo l'opportunità,
perché la Internet degli oggetti è oggi,
e la possibilità di influenzarla attraverso il design
è adesso.
Credo sia necessario, a questo punto, avendola citata più volte,
dare una qualche definizione di Internet degli oggetti.
La più generica,
e forse la più semplice, che mi viene in mente,
è semplicemente quella che dice:
sentiamo la pulsione, dal punto di vista del mercato,
ma anche dal punto di vista delle persone,
di sostituire gli oggetti che abbiamo,
e che sono non connessi,
con oggetti che sono connessi,
approfittando di questa opportunità di sostituzione
per aggiungere qualità senzienti:
sensori che ci daranno la possibilità
di fare cose nuove,
o di fare cose più accuratamente,
o di avere nuovi modelli di business --
ne abbiamo appena avuto una grandissima dimostrazione.
E ogni, come dire,
evoluzione ha un suo PONG
e a me piace pensare --
e in questo sono d'accordo con Rafi Haladjian
che l'ha disegnato, progettato e voluto produrre sul mercato --
che il PONG di questa Internet degli oggetti
tutto sommato sia il Nabaztag, questo simpatico coniglio,
con le orecchie semoventi,
capace di riprodurre dei suoni
che erano stati registati da qualcun altro, su un altro coniglio
Rafi me ne regalò uno,
e io ci giocai con mia figlia, che allora aveva due anni.
E l'ha fatto -- come dire --
il fatto emotivo, la capacità emotiva che aveva quel coniglio
attraverso i movimenti delle orecchie,
le luci, la riproduzione dei suoni --
ha fatto sì che fosse subito bene accetto.
Ma questo non gli ha impedito,
nel giro più o meno di un anno,
di finire in un cassetto, di finire dimenticato.
Beh, anche per onorare il coraggio imprenditoriale di Rafi,
a me piace dire che un esercito di 250 000 conigli
è stato sacrificato nel tentativo
di capire le dinamiche della Internet degli oggetti;
di capire che cosa avremmo fatto,
con questa nuova fase di evoluzione.
E se il numero 250 000 vi sembra un numero importante,
beh, quest'altro numero, cioè 50 miliardi
di oggetti connessi entro il 2020,
beh, dovrebbe darvi la scossa.
E per cercare di tracciare una curva,
per capire dove siamo rispetto a questa crescita,
la domanda potrebbe essere:
fare un paragone con la quantità di esseri umani
che abbiamo sulla Terra.
Quando accadrà
che il numero degli oggetti connessi che costruiamo
supererà il numero degli esseri umani?
È già accaduto!
È già accaduto nel 2008,
ed essendo già passati tre anni,
tre anni sono una quantità di tempo
così imponente da differenziare,
per esempio, Internet pre-Google da quella post-Google,
Internet pre-Facebook da quella post-Facebook.
E abbiamo idea, oggi,
di che cosa voglia dire questo genere di impatto?
E qui, per vedere le cose un po' più da distante,
un po' più dall'alto,
e cercare in qualche modo di comprenderle,
vi chiedo di venire un attimo in orbita con me
e, tutto sommato, di provare a guardare il mondo
davvero da vicino.
Il termine che vorrei usare è questo:
penso che sia evidente a tutti
che le migliori qualità umane,
la più grande capacità di design,
la tecnologia più rilevante che abbiamo adoperato
è quella che abbiamo adoperato
per la conquista dello spazio.
Però, oggi,
abbiamo circa sedicimila corpi di dimensione di circa 10 centimetri,
che chiamiamo "Spacejunk"
e ho saputo oggi da fonte diretta
che gli astronauti della base spaziale
che abbiamo visto oggi in orbita --
bene, più o meno 5 volte l'anno
incorrono in un allarme perché uno degli oggetti
che determina la Spacejunk è per loro pericoloso.
Bene: se 250 000 conigli
sono diventati "beautiful junk" così rapidamente,
io mi chiedo che cosa possa succedere a 50 miliardi di oggetti
se questi non saranno progettati
almeno bene come quello che noi mandiamo in orbita.
E per entrare un po' più
nella qualità di progettazione che noi usiamo,
prenderò a riferimento quello che tutti percepiamo
come uno dei settori, come dire?
più tutelati, legalmente,
più tutelati dal punto di vista anche dell'attenzione che si mette,
perché ha a che fare con la nostra salute ogni giorno.
Ma il mondo dell'health care, della salute,
non è separato da quello che sta succedendo fuori:
la progressiva digitalizzazione
di tutto ciò che riguarda il nostro quotidiano
ci dà un incremento di velocità veramente molto importante:
oggi noi possiamo studiare
attraverso, che so, il Google Body browser,
il corpo umano con una, tutto sommato, facilità
e con una precisione che quando io ero al liceo
era semplicemente fantascienza.
La stessa fantascienza dei libri di Asimov,
niente di diverso!
E se pensiamo che la medicina,
perché più tutelata, perché più tranquilla, perché più prudente,
sia distante dai fenomeni di Internet in generale,
beh, non è poi così vero:
PatientsLikeMe è come Facebook, ma condivide dati in medicina.
La geomedicina è una applicazione che, tutto sommato,
se non esistesse Google Maps,
probabilmente non sarebbe stata immaginata.
E tutto questo sta cambiando l'health care
e sta cambiando l'intera società.
E un dispositivo portatile
che misura le nostre condizioni mediche in tempo reale,
continuamente, è alla porta, ce lo avremo molto presto.
Questo in particolare è stato annunciato alla TED conference
e sarà in commercio a gennaio.
Ebbene, tutto questo mi porta a dire
che anche il mondo più prudente,
nella Internet degli oggetti, tutto sommato
sta proliferando una quantità di oggetti,
una biodiversità così vasta da sembrare quasi,
anzi una invasione di oggetti
che si prenderanno cura di noi!
Mi sto già sentendo meglio, da questo punto di vista,
perché so che sarò tutelato.
Ma il prossimo passo
non sarà quello di una umanità avanzata
o una umanità amplificata,
di nanorobotica e di cose che, appunto,
ci sembrano ancora da fantascienza.
Il prossimo passo è già accaduto,
e lo troviamo in qualunque negozio.
Questo è l'Apple Store di New York,
e quel bancone sono prodotti medicali di fascia consumer,
tutto sotto i 100 dollari.
Ma ti puoi misurare la pressione sanguigna,
puoi tenere sotto controllo il tuo comportamento --
parlo dal punto di vista medico --
e da questo punto di vista si sta completamente incrinando
quella che era la relazione mediata e piena di infrastrutture,
piena di barriere tra, per esempio, medico e paziente.
Uno dei più grandi progetti
legati al mondo della salute negli ultimi anni
è stato Google Health.
Monitoriamo la salute del pianeta!
Ebbene, questo progetto è stato chiuso,
è stato chiuso qualche mese fa.
E secondo la persona
che per un anno e mezzo lo ha portato avanti, Adam Bosworth,
il motivo è: non era abbastanza sociale.
Ed è strano perché, insomma,
hai a che fare con dati veramente critici
quindi il fatto di essere sociali
non dovrebbe essere la cosa più importante.
Ma lo stesso giorno hanno chiuso anche quest'altro progetto,
che è il Google Energy Meter.
Il Google Energy Meter
si poneva l'obiettivo davvero fantastico
di ridurre i consumi energetici del pianeta.
E per questo cosa bisognava fare?
Bastava misurare i consumi di ognuno!
In realtà tutto questo non è sufficiente.
Non è sufficiente perché per avere un cambiamento globale
noi dobbiamo coinvolgere le persone.
E a questo, serve il design.
Io ho passato gli ultimi anni
a progettare alcune bizzarrie:
sensori di CO2 che prendono il dato di concentrazione,
quindi, della CO2 puntuale e lo spediscono sulla rete.
A cosa serve?
Serve perché, per esempio,
la granularità di queste detection
ci danno una mappa di dove la CO2 è prodotta,
non solo di dove è distribuita.
Oppure progettare coccodrilli USB, zeppi di sensori
che collegandosi in tempo reale con i social network
diventavano un'estensione di gioco!
E abbiano progettato anche delle cose
che abbiamo chiamato, come questo,
Social Energy Meter,
per appunto monitorare i consumi
e cambiare le abitudini delle persone.
Ma le abitudini delle persone
hanno bisogno di stimoli sociali,
e questo, che si chiama "Social energy meter"
non a caso, ha la caratteristica di ridarmi,
come feedback, non solo il mio consumo in tempo reale,
ma anche il consumo di un benchmark che io ho scelto.
Io come utente, quindi per me è significativo:
magari sono le persone che vivono nel mio palazzo,
o magari sono quattro amici
sparpagliati nei quattro continenti.
In ogni caso,
quando il loro consumo medio, che è indicato da un colore,
è migliore del mio consumo medio
beh, so chi è il cattivo.
Devo alzarmi, e andare a spegnere la luce,
o fare qualcosa di questo genere.
La crowdsourced ecology, l'ecologia dal basso --
per esempio, utilizzando un banalissimo iPhone,
l'ecologia che può avere a che fare
con la detection del rumore, le mappe del rumore
sono una cosa che possiamo affrontare ogni giorno,
e fanno parte di un universo ampio
che sta collegando ogni palazzo,
pianta, automobile e tutto il resto alla rete Internet.
Per me questo non è altro
che mettere delle anime di software nelle cose,
e queste anime di software
sono molto simili al disegno di Gaia,
e questo sta avvenendo così rapidamente
che ritengo sia utile e urgente avere un piano.
E questo è un pezzo del piano.
Sono le leggi del design
che immodestamente sto cercando di promuovere:
promuoverle perché, sostanzialmente,
sono abbastanza stanco di avere un'auto
zeppa di sensori così riservata
da non dire mai niente al mio telefonino.
O avere un telefonino che si collega con qualunque cosa,
ma mai e poi mai parlerebbe con l'auto:
questi due settori dell'industria devono parlarsi,
perché il conto lo stiamo ovviamente pagando noi.
E usare il design vuol dire --
e torno ad Asimov --
occuparsi dei comportamenti.
Quali comportamenti ci servono, oggi?
Questa è la proposta: sono tre leggi,
il numero non è casuale.
La prima dice che gli oggetti
dovrebbero essere in grado di conoscere delle storie.
La storia del loro passato,
come sono stati fatti, da dove vengono,
e la storia del loro futuro.
Ok, finito il ciclo di vita, come lo smonto,
come lo valorizzo, come rientra nel giro
e non diventa spacejunk?
E ho bisogno anche che questi oggetti siano connessi.
Ho bisogno che questi oggetti siano senzienti,
cioè non un navigatore satellitare,
una mappa e un orologio,
che abbiano la pretesa di condurmi ovunque,
ma qualcosa, come un'auto che abbiamo visto oggi,
che esplora il mondo circostante
e quindi è capace di conoscerlo, in qualche modo.
E abbiamo anche bisogno
che questi oggetti siano sociali: è fondamentale.
Ma "sociali" vuol dire:
che partecipano alle relazioni umane.
Vuol dire, sostanzialmente,
che questi oggetti hanno la capacità
di comunicare nella stessa rete che usiamo noi,
perché persone e macchine
devono condividere la stessa rete.
Queste sono, penso, le condizioni,
le caratteristiche e i comportamenti
che ci potrebbero oggi aiutare
a progettare degli oggetti migliori,
e fanno la stessa differenza da ieri
di quanto l'era industriale,
quindi gli oggetti che progettano noi stessi --
perché utilizzando un oggetto
veniamo influenzati nel nostro modo di essere --
e diventano degli oggetti
che sfruttano fondamentalmente la loro capacità,
proprio, mutevole e, come dire, mutante,
di essere diversi attraverso il layer digitale.
Per fare un piccolo switch, per me fondamentale:
passare da essere la conseguenza degli oggetti che usiamo,
ad essere, probabilmente,
la conseguenza degli oggetti che progettiamo.
E la differenza, per me,
è l'aspirazione umana.
Ho finito.
(Applausi)